P A to hold on. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad wow, that wasn't big. Sorry.
I was just feeling it. I was feeling it. [inaudible] I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab. We, yeah, we have been,
and we shouldn't be laughing cause we'd been listening to a really,
really sad story about a chimp named Lucy who was born as a chimp,
raised as a human and died in well under because she ran into a human that she
trusted and probably shouldn't have. Yeah.
And so the question that we want to ask now,
and we asked this question to Charles Siebert, you know,
guy who wrote a lot about chimps is,
what's the lesson that we should draw from this? It's good question.
I think what it says,
it points back to something they said earlier that the only option now in the
best way to dignify and honor what they are,
who they are,
they're more than once is to fence them ourselves off from them in little
pockets of their home that we leave alone.
That would be coexistence
[inaudible]
if you can't do it that way.
And there's a very good reason why he couldn't do it that way because they were,
what, six now?
6.8 billion people in the world soon to up to 9 billion to many of us,
too many of them. So what do you do? Well, one thing you might try,
I mean it's kind of a far out notion,
but you could go back to the Lucy experiment that when we just described it
ended very badly. Yeah, but this time you do it. How should I put this?
You do it differently.
This test is to displace an in Iowa where this is kind of happening,
kind of.
You sent our producer store [inaudible] to check it out and ready to go visit to
savage Roomba. So to set things up, what was the name of this place?
The great eight trust, although I think the name is kind of in flux, but anyway,
the great ape trust, which is this place in the morning and I will wear 'em.
It's kind of like a compound where they keep a very special group of Bonobos.
Is it Bonobos or bone Boson? Then how do they say it? I think they say bonobos.
Hmm.
[inaudible] working again.
So when I got there, bill fields, who's the director of the place?
Director of scientific research, that's him right there. Hi.
In banella Saudis Hill took me inside and then there's this place where they
keep the Banabos but bill had to kind of go in there ahead of me and ask
if they are ready to see me. Do you want the visitor to come see?
That's good. Okay. Alright. We're going to do,
we're going to bring the visitor to see you
and I walk into this room,
which is this kind of big concrete room [inaudible] here the rules are when
they're visitors that the Benobos are kind of kept behind this fence. Oh,
there's a fence in the room. Yeah.
And just on the other side of the fence is kind of
what does look like. Is he big? He's
pretty [inaudible]
big.
Maybe if he stood completely upright, yeah,
you'd be a little bit shorter than I am. But he's built and more than that,
he's just got this kind of presence
[inaudible]
chances. I mean he, he looks at
you like directly in the eye. He was standing
there with his arms just kind of swinging. Those fingers are amazing.
They're SAS office. It's not like going to a zoo.
It's a little bit more like there's another person on the other side of that
wire.
[inaudible]
here's one of the first things that Kanzi does when I come in.
Like there's these two and they're like a big plastic salad bowl.
You take these two big plastic salad bowls
down on the concrete and put his hands on him and run them
around the room.
A round circle?
Yes.
Slams himself up against the wire. Wow. Why?
What do you think he was doing? I didn't know what to say.
Thanks. Can you say
you did?
Okay. What's with
[inaudible] microphone. So here's, here's Kanzi story. Sue,
would you remember sue from the last story?
Susan heavy trombone after she worked with Lucy, this is about 30 years ago.
She got Kanzi and she raised it. I mean she from a little bitty Bonobo,
but she would, you know, carry Kanzi around with her all the time. Loving him.
As much as I love my son, she becomes light watch movies.
When we went to bed at night and they had a mother [inaudible].
This sounds a little bit like the Lucy thing,
but the difference here is that with Kanji we never wanted to take him away from
his mother.
Metatron Kanzi also has a Banaba mother Patato was born in the Congo,
so she carried the knowledge of the bonobos culture as best she could across the
[inaudible]. I was a member of a different species.
I had a different kind of language,
a human kind of language who says that the whole idea of the experiment was to
create kind of an emotional bond,
no bond between her and Kanzi that would fill Kanzi with an an innate desire to
understand what I was going to say,
to understand how it felt to want to communicate with me.
And so pretty soon Kanzi is using this.
They have a kind of a special keyboard with these symbols and you can touch the
symbol. It makes a computer voice as a word. Hey,
can you buy milk milk?
He's using this symbol keyboard to communicate with sue
sue Mary.
This is the two of them sitting in front of the keyboard practicing enough.
And how many words can you do? Go for 600 really? Yeah.
Wow.
And then this is where to me it just gets a z.
As he got older, started being able to communicate without the keyboard.
She would talk to him and he would talk back.
Matt,
give me an example of what it was when I was there.
There was one point where we are outside. We're here. Cathy, where are you?
Like Kanzi has this outside space and we're outside too,
but he's still fenced in like before and bill and Kanzi are having this kind of
back and forth. What's out there?
Can you say something?
Kanzi seems to be saying there's something I want to show you or there's
something you need to see. It's not quite clear what's going on.
I don't see it yet. And Bill can't quite figure it out either.
So Kanzi takes us then from the tool side over this other place where there's
out in the yard, there's this big pit for down here and look at that.
We can't see into, cause we're behind this fence,
but Kanzi is basically pointing down in the pit down in the hole here we go in
the whole year to go in to look at that man and according to bill and sue saying
there's something there. How is Kanzi saying this? I mean,
well I mean to you and me you, it sound like,
I mean like I, I could tell that Kanzi was gesturing at something,
but when dangerous
bill and sue are hearing words.
So it was, it got pee.
It's got teeth, it's got big teeth and you want us to get rid of it?
Are you scared of it? Not Too much.
You can handle it.
Well I can't come in there right now but I can in a little bit and we'll check
it out. We were so interested in this situation that you're hearing right here.
It's too cold out here. I'll come on. Look, I'll come in love. What is like,
are they really talking? So we decided to call up bill fields. Hello? Hello?
Hello? Hello. This is bill. Hey Bill.
So we heard a bit of tape that Soren recorded where you guys were outside and
Kanzi was pointing in a hole or something and it just sounded like you guys are
having some kind of real bilingual exchange. I mean,
is that really what was happening? Yes, that's what was happening.
We have begun to be able to decode his speech. If you say Kanzi,
what do you want for breakfast? He'll point on the Lexa Graham keyboard.
He wanted grapes, onions, tofu. Say, okay,
I'm going to go tell everybody we're going to have grapes, onions, and Tofu.
And he will just respond with right now, like vocally? Yes.
What does that sound like? I'm going to see if I can do so.
What's in English? Yes. Oh Man, yes.
When he speaks to me and I understand it, it's an English.
The first time it happened, Bill,
he was a Grad student and he and Kanzi were outside.
I was sitting on a stump and Kanzi was sort of in a field nearby,
but at a certain point he says, Kanzi stopped what he was doing.
Turned right bill, and I'll do my best to reproduce it for you.
He said to me
like that. He said what? He said chase, but it was very hard for him to say it.
But don't you just ask yourself like really am I sure that's what I heard?
Not Anymore. I used to.
It is such a common occurrence in our lab and it's not just my experience,
it's my staff's experiences, Sue's experience and so on. What about you?
I mean you were there. Do you buy what he's saying? Kanzi speaks words. Ah,
yeah. I still don't know. Yeah, I mean the science isn't there,
but what I do buy is that there's,
there's real communication going on and I think it may be like a new kind of
communication, like something,
this is something I don't think has happened anywhere else. I've,
bill and sue have literally created a third culture,
a culture that neither just bonobos or just human is something,
it's something in between.
And I think that that culture and those relationships are real.
Yeah. Now the weird thing about that is that with all the,
all the great things that come out of that, there are also moments of,
of real confusion. Like what? Well, what,
one time we had a principal investigator who was visiting the lab at that time
and she was having a very strong disagreement with, uh,
Dr. Savage rumbar about method and this really upset Kanzi.
Why was the investigators screaming at sue? Or what was she doing?
Why do you call him an investigator? Is that like,
this is some kind of some kind of academic visitor? Is that what we need?
That's how scientists are referred to. You have the principal investigator,
the co-investigator, and it's not Colombo with a gun packing a gun.
This is like just some guy from some college somewhere.
It's a scientific investigator. Okay. So just to fill out the scene,
you've got a Su bill and this investigator in one room and Kanzi in a different
room behind some glass, very thick, clear glass.
So Kanzi can actually see what's happening in their room.
You can see that this investigator is getting angry with sue,
his human mom getting more and more animated.
It was professionally aggressive and loud. And what was the,
what was the argument about, do you remember? Oh yes.
It was about the format that we were going to use for archive video.
That's it. Well, you know,
been flipped over stupid.
And as soon this lady are arguing what was Kanzi doing,
he was banging on the window. So I, I went to, to speak to him.
He walked into Kanzi Room Kanzi then went to the keyboard and told him,
you have to punish that investigator for screaming at zoo. He didn't want,
he wanted me to go in there and, and stop her from doing this.
It was my responsibility to take care of things and that if I didn't do it,
he was going to bite me.
Were you being told man up this woman as being attacked and you're supposed to
pound or bite that investigator and if you don't fight her, I will bite you.
Is that essentially? Yes. And I defaulted to human culture.
I said, Conti, I really can't go argue. I can't interfere.
I just defaulted to the way things would happen in the human world.
And so later I told sue that Dundee told me he was going to bite me and said
consciously not could it by year. And um,
24 hours later after he threatened to bite me,
he says that sue was putting Kanzi back in his enclosure,
but Kanzi pushed past her, ran down the hall, found bill in his office,
came and found me and he bit me. You Bet. [inaudible] where did he bunny you?
Um, on the hand. It was, it was really serious. Uh, I lost a finger.
Jeez.
What happened was the hand would spit and then they had to reattach all of the
ligaments. Southern rest of my hand would work. Wow.
I had three surgeries that week. The first one was 14 hours.
The next one was about eight hours and the third one was about three hours.
But the problem was I apparently had sensitivities to drugs we didn't know about
and they had given me morphine and I arrested.
It stopped my breathing and my heart. You almost died? Yes.
Wow. Is there,
did you think if you'd been there then he wouldn't have beaten you?
I'm certain of it. Yeah. So what did you do then? I mean,
did you just come back to the lab and then nothing happened or,
I came back to the lab about 14 days after the event. Um,
I was not ready to, but, uh, I, I didn't know what else to do,
but for eight months I didn't speak to z and he kept trying to make up with me.
How would he do that? Would he, would he, he typed in his keyboard, sorry.
He never, he would, he refuse to tell me he was sorry.
But he would keep calling me bill since he'd use the keyboard to ask the other
researchers to get bill, get bill and what do you want me to do?
She's come down and renew my friendship with them and just act like nothing had
happened. And, uh, I simply wouldn't go and see him.
And suet came to me and tried to talk me into going into same and I said,
we're in cons. He's ready to apologize, but she come back and say, no,
cause he's not gonna apologize. He doesn't think he should. And, uh, I,
I just stood on my ground, you know. Kenzie's gonna apologize to me.
Finally, one afternoon and eight months later,
one of his colleagues came up to him and,
and told him kinds he wants to tell you he's sorry.
And as soon as I got down there,
he threw his body up against the wire pressing up against me and he just
screamed and screamed in my mouth, which was this very submissive scream.
It was very clear. He was sorry.
And he was trying to make up with me and I asked him on the keyboard,
are you sorry? And he told me yes. And when you,
when you say he threw himself against the Y, I mean against the,
against the separating device between you and him. Yes.
Anus pressed his body up against that wire.
And so I put my body up against him and we just pressed up against each other.
Do you see what's happening here?
You're telling us a story which reads more and more and more like a soap opera
between a community of beings.
The fact that one of them is a little Bonobo and the other one is a guy is
almost incidental to this story.
It's like I could put this on channel five if I wanted. It's,
it's just private
[inaudible] just pregnancy
[inaudible] man.
Currently the great ape trust is, it's not just Kanzi.
There's about seven different Banabos there and a dozen or so kind of staff and
researchers and while they're certainly not the same,
they have created at the very least some, some middle ground.
And for sue,
that's not about a solution to any conservation problem or some scientific
breakthrough. It's, it's something deeper and more personal.
When I am with Bonobos,
I feel like I have something that I shared with him long ago,
but I forgot.
As we've closed ourselves and separated ourselves,
we've gained a wonderful society,
but we've lost a kind of soul to soul connection that they maintain
[inaudible]
and it sometimes seems to me as though we're both the a kind of a [inaudible]
a disadvantaged species. They have things that I've lost.
I have things that that they don't have.
I feel like if I could have their abilities and keep mine
[inaudible]
I would be whole.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you can find more information about anything that you heard in this hour at our
website,
radiolab.org we've also got Lucy pictures and Janis Kanzi pictures there,
and you can subscribe to our podcast that's at radiolab.org I'm Jen up and Rod.
I'm Robert Krulwich
listening.